[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine Lieben Zuschauer in den letzten
Tagen beschäftigen sich die großen
Medien damit dass es mit dem
Voranschreiten der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive für Russland auf dem
Schlachtfeld immer düsterer aussieht
natürlich ist es sehr wichtig dass
Russland seinen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
verliert allerdings muss uns auch
folgendes klar sein um wirklich
dauerhaften Frieden in Europa erreicht
zu können wird noch viel mehr nötig sein
als das es geht darum den
imperialistischen glücksten Russlands
ein für alle Mal den Rücken zu brechen
so wie ist die Alliierten 1945 mit denen
Deutschlands getan haben denn genauso
wie von deutschen Boden aus nie wieder
ein Krieg ausgehen sollte müssen auch im
Falle Russlands alle Bedingungen für die
absolute Befriedung dieses unruhestiftes
geschaffen werden eines der
Hauptargumente mit dem Moskau seinen
grausam Überfall auf sein Nachbarland
zurechtfertigen versuchte war ja das ist
gezwungen war die NATO um jeden Preis
daran zu hindern weiter nach Osten zu
expandieren laut der russischen
Regierung handelt es sich dabei eine
absolut inakzeptable Bedrohung Russlands
und irgendwie klingt dieses Jahr doch
sehr auch nach Hitlers perverser
Rechtfertigung für seinen Krieg und
Völkermord damals war es eben die mehr
vom Weltjudentum dass eine inakzeptable
Bedrohung des deutschen Volkes
darstellen würde deswegen müsste
Deutschland die ganze Welt erobern und
Millionen von Menschen abschlachten ja
Putin hat eben Stalin halt noch viele
weitere Vorbilder in der Geschichte aber
ironischerweise haben die Dinge wie im
Zweiten Weltkrieg auch jetzt wieder eine
Wendung um 180 Grad genommen die
russische Invasion der Ukraine hat
Länder wie Finnland und Schweden dazu
gebracht über eine Änderung ihres Status
nachzudenken hatten sie es bisher
vorgezogen unabhängig und unbedingt
neutral zu bleiben hatte Invasion Sie
davon überzeugt dass dies nicht mehr
ratsam ist sie sahen sich quasi durch
Russland gezwungen der NATO beizutreten
und Finnland tat dies dann auch im April
Tomorrowland
thirty first
Schweden allerdings hat es viel
schwieriger 11 September 2023 Türkei
stellt Schweden NATO Abkommen wieder in
Frage am 10 Juli sah es wie eine
beschlossene Sache aus als der türkische
Präsident Recep Tayyip Erdogan dem
schwedischen Premierminister auf die
NATO Gipfel in Vilnius die Hand
schüttelte doch die Türkei hat die
Aufmerksamkeit von der Koranverbrennung
auf die US Kampfflugzeuge verlagert und
behandelt endlos über den NATO-Beitritt
Schweden sein 22 September 2023
ungarische schwedensator Ratifizierung
weiterhin blockieren Ungarn ist der
einzige EU-Mitgliedstaat der den
weiteren Schwedens noch nicht
ratifiziert hat Budapest drückte seine
Unzufriedenheit über die unfreundlichen
Äußerungen schwedischer Politiker über
Ungarn aus und schickte eine Delegation
nach Stockholm um Gespräche zu führen oh
ja es ist eine riesiges hin und her auf
dass wir in diesem Video eingehen wird
Schweden das 32 Mitglied des
atlantischen Bündnisses werden oder
nicht und wieso ist dies überhaupt so
wichtig nun wir haben euch bereits in
einem Video über die Folgen der Invasion
dass wir übrigens schon acht Tage vor
ihrem Beginn veröffentlicht hatten
erklärt dass die russische Aggression
die NATO-Mitgliedschaft das Skandinavier
zur Folge haben und dass dies für
Russland einen gravierenden Rückschlag
bedeuten wird bisher hat der Creme die
Souveränität der Ukraine immer wieder
mit dem Vorwand bedroht dass er die
NATO-Erweiterung bis an die Grenzen
Russlands eindämmen will nun das
Ergebnis einer Invasion wird aus drei
Gründen zum genauen Gegenteil führen
erstens könnte ein Einmarsch in die
Ukraine mindestens zwei neue Länder
Schweden und Finnland dazu veranlassen
ihre Sicherheit durch den Beitritt zur
NATO abzusichern
ja es handelt sich nur um eine der
vielen Prognosen aus diesem Video den
vollem Umfang eingetreten sind übrigens
wurden wir damals von vielen dafür
belacht dass wir überhaupt mit einem
Angriff Putins rechneten und
gleichzeitig der Ukraine gute Chancen
gaben ihn abzuwehren klar wir
widersprachen damit deutlich den breiten
politischen medialen und auch
akademischen Konsens der Russland noch
immer für die zweitstärkste Militär
Macht der Welt hielt die die Ukraine in
wenigen Tagen über rennen würde und
deren Sicherheitsinteressen man aus
Gründen der Realpolitik um jeden Preis
respektieren müssen schaut euch dieses
Video doch ruhig noch mal an und
Vergleich dann im dortigen
Kommentarbereich wie sich die Reaktion
darauf im Laufe der Zeit von vor der
Invasion mit ihrem beginnen und mit den
ersten Anzeichen von scheitern moskauz
verändert haben und macht euch doch mal
den Spaß auch auf ganz alte Kommentare
zu antworten sicher bekommen einige der
damaligen Putin Fans oder Angsthasen
noch eine Benachrichtigung aber der
Grund wieso all das was schließlich
passiert ist für uns keine so große
Überraschung darstellte lag darin schon
viel früher Russlands militärisches
Potenzial analysiert hatten und zum
Schluss gekommen waren dass der Kreml
viel mehr eine paradearmee vorhält als
eine Streitmacht die in der Lage ist
komplex Operation mit kombinierten
Waffengattungen durchzuführen wie zum
Beispiel in einem noch früheren Video
von uns aus dem Jahr 2020 dass ich euch
verlinken werde fakt ist jedoch das Pute
nicht nur bei seiner armee-reform
versagt hat sondern auch auf dem ebenso
wichtigen diplomatischen Feld schauen
wir uns in diesem Zusammenhang mal die
typischen Botschaften an die über die
Jahre hinweg aus dem Kreml kamen 18 juni
2015 russische Botschafter wenn Schweden
der Natur beiträgt wird es Konsequenzen
geben Putin wie es darauf hin dass es
Konsequenzen geben wird das Russland
militärisch Antworten und unsere Truppen
und Raketen umlenken muss sagte der
russische Botschafter Viktor tatininsel
4 Februar 2016 Russland simuliert
Atomangriff auf Schweden tja auf diese
Weise schafft man sich weder Freunde
noch Neutralität tatsächlich hat man in
Russland die Rolle des Skandinavia
ebenso wie die Widerstandskraft der
Ukraine über Jahre hinweg maßlos
unterschätzt welche fataler Fehler mit
einer Fläche von rund 450.000
Quadratkilometer und fast 11 Millionen
Einwohnern ist Schweden das flächenmäßig
drittgrößte Land der Europäischen Union
und die größte Industrie macht
Skandinaviens die Frage lautet also
warum ist Schweden für den Keller so
wichtig was genau bedeutet die Aufnahme
dieses Landes für die NATO ist das
wirklich etwas worüber sich Russland
Sorgen machen sollte was alles von nun
an ändere im heutigen Video werden wir
all diese spannenden Fragen natürlich
beantworten zuvor müssen wir euch jedoch
eine wichtige Botschaft überbringen hört
sich Euch bitte bis zum Ende an denn
dieses Thema betrifft wirklich uns alle
das heutige Video hat nämlich in die
Möglichkeit gemacht ein Sponsor der euch
aktiv von Datenmissbrauch durch
sogenannte data Broker schützen kann
data Broker sind Daten die unsere
persönlichen Daten über alle Netz
sammeln und abgreifen und danach nicht
nur an seriöse Unternehmen verkaufen
sondern auch an Betrüger diese Betrüger
bombardieren uns damit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-Mails oder versuchen
und sogar auszunehmen Nachteile durch
die Verarbeitung deiner Daten müssen die
aber nicht erst durch betrügen erwachsen
hast du dir schon mal überlegt wer alles
aus deinen Daten Rückschlüsse über dich
ziehen könnte teilweise sind sie ja
sogar falsch bzw verfälscht oder können
eine viel Interpretation deines
Verhaltens im Netz darstellen und dann
wunderst du dich warum du zum Beispiel
vom neuen Arbeitgeber oder Vermieter
abgelehnt wirst plötzlich höhere
Versicherungsbeiträge zahlen muss oder
kein Kredit von der Bank bekommst und
zwar ohne jemals den wahren Grund dafür
zu erfahren genau leider haben wir
keinerlei Kontrolle darüber an wen alles
die data Broker unsere Daten verkaufen
und was Ihre Kunden dann daraus gegen
uns stricken aber es gibt zum Glück
einen Ausweg aus diesem Albtraum die
data Broker sind nämlich gesetzlich dazu
verpflichtet unsere Daten zu löschen
wenn wir sie dazu auffordern das Problem
dabei es gibt Tausende von ihnen oft ist
der Antragsprozess Absicht nicht
kompliziert gestaltet deswegen
resignieren viele Menschen einfach und
lassen den ganzen Schmuck passiv über
sich ergehen der Sponsor dieses Videos
inkognit bietet genau dafür jedoch eine
Lösung inkognit übernimmt die Aufgabe
bei den data Brokern für uns aufzuräumen
und alle lösch-anträge zu stellen du
meldest dich einfach bei inkognit
anbeauftragte in deinem Namen die
Löschanträge rechtlich durchzusetzen und
verfolgst dann bequem auf eine
übersichtlichen Dashboard wie deine
Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden ohne einen solchen Service
wäre es beim normalen Menschen nahezu
unmöglich diese Anträge alles selbst zu
bearbeiten und sich so vor Betrug und
allen anderen Nachteilen zu schützen
also du was gutes für deine datenhygiene
und schau dir inkogniz sofort über den
Link in der Videobeschreibung an
außerdem mit den promoco Politik die
erhältst du auch noch 60% Rabatt wenn du
zu den ersten 100 gehörst die nutzen und
falls Du uns etwas zu tun möchtest
ebenfalls in der Videobeschreibung
findest du ein Spenden Link mit dem du
unsere Arbeit auf freiwilliger Basis
finanziell unterstützen kannst an dieser
Stelle schon mal vielen herzlichen Dank
von uns allen so und wenn ihr dies
erledigt habt lasst uns wieder zum Thema
unseres Videos zurückkehren um nämlich
die ganze Geschichte zu verstehen müssen
wir ganz am Anfang beginnen aufgepasst
[Musik]
Imperium zur Neutralität
in der Kultur und in der populären
Vorstellungen neigen wir dazu Schweden
als einen ruhigen und gemäßigten Staat
zu sehen eine Bastion des sozialen
Friedens und Synonym für moderne
Sozialdemokratie aber das war natürlich
nicht immer der Fall die Vergangenheit
ist Landes war viel schrecklicher das
schwedische Reichwein 17 Jahrhundert
eine der stärksten europäischen
Militärmächte zu dieser Zeit umfasste
sein Direktorium auch das heutige
Finnland Estland und einen großen Teil
Norwegens aber die Frage ist warum wir
euch das überhaupt die provisorpolitik
erzählen nun weil die Konfiguration ist
heutigen Territorium sind diese ganzen
Region Europas auf der Ereignisse des
sogenannten Großen Nordischen Krieges
zurückzuführen ist wir sprechen hier von
einem Konflikt der zwischen 1700 und
1721 stattfand in diesem Jahr führte das
schwedische Reich in den bewaffneten
Konflikt gegen Russland Dänemark und
Norwegen sie kämpften um die
Vorherrschaft im Ostseeraum
der Konflikt endete mit dem Vertrag von
newstart im Jahr 1721 und in diesem
Vertrag wurde Schweden vom russischen
Zarismus quasi unterjocht aber das ist
noch nicht alles einige Jahre später
zwischen 180 und brachte sogenannte
Krieg aus in dem Russland erneut über
schwedente nach diesem Krieg kam das
große Finnland unter die Kontrolle
Russland
und so wurde Russland nach und nach zu
einer großen baltischen macht dieses
Meer war nicht länger eine Art
exklusiver Wasserweg des schwedischen
Reiches sondern wurde mit der Zeit zum
natürlichen Zugang der russischen Flotte
zu den Weltmeeren
[Musik]
Schweden seiner Satz verfolgte seit dem
19 Jahrhundert nachdem es sein früheres
Reich verloren hatte eine Politik der
Neutralität die Neuordnung des Staates
und die Entwicklung des Landes wurden zu
seinen wichtigsten Prioritäten statt
sein Heil in immer während der Expansion
zu suchen wenn man sich lieber auf die
Verbesserung der eigenen inneren Werte
tja vielleicht wäre auch dies ein gutes
Rezept für die Zukunft Russland nicht
wahr nun wir sprechen hier von einer
Neutralität die mehr als 150 Jahre lang
anhielt und im Grunde nur während des
Zweiten Weltkriegs in Frage gestellt
wurde wohlgemerkt in Frage gestellt aber
nicht gebrochen offiziell schloss sich
Schweden auch damals keine der beiden
Seiten an später im Jahr 1949 also
Zweite Weltkrieg bereits im Kalten Krieg
gewichen war entschied sich Stockholm
der NATO fern zu bleiben und erklärte
eine Sicherheitspolitik die auf
Unabhängigkeit und absoluter Neutralität
basierte
[Musik]
in den 1990er Jahren wurde Schweden
allerdings von einer Welle pro
europäischer Begeisterung erfasst so
dass das Land 1995 schließlich beschloss
mit seiner historischen Staatspolitik
zumindest auf nicht militärische Ebene
zu brechen und der Europäischen Union
beizutreten darüber hinaus blieb es zwar
außerhalb der NATO verstärkte aber seine
Beziehung zu dieser Organisation in all
diesen Jahren hat es zum Beispiel als
Partner als verbitterte aber nicht als
Mitglied an den NATO einsetzen in
Bosnien im Kosovo nach Afghanistan und
auch in Libyen teilgenommen
und das ist noch nicht alles 2017
schloss sich Schweden zusammen mit
Finnland Norwegen Estland Irland und
Litauen der norwegische Group Kurs Nbg
an einer der gefäßverbände der
Europäischen Union der Hauptquartier
sich in der schwedische Stadt
entköppingen befindet eine Reserve von
2400 Soldaten aus all diesen Ländern ist
dort stationiert
[Musik]
mit anderen Worten die schwedische
Neutralität begann sich immer schneller
zur verfüchtigen etwas mit dem ob man es
glaubt oder nicht Wladimir Putin nichts
zu tun hatte und was werdet ihr Fragen
hat der russische Staatschef getan nur
im Grunde tat er das was am besten kann
erstattete eine permanente
Einschüchterungskampagne sein Ziel um
jeden Preis zu verhindern dass Schweden
dem atlantischen Bündnis Beitritt 11
September 2014 beispiellose russische
Militäraktion im Baltikum der polnische
Verteidigungsministerium und ja gesagt
dass die meisten Aktivitäten in
internationalen Gewässern und im
Luftraum stattfanden und Schweden das am
meisten betroffene Land war die 24 märz
2015 Schweden fängt russische
Militärflugzeuge ab die mit
ausgeschalteten Transpondern über der
ausserregion flogen 26 Oktober 2016
Russland verstärkt die baltische Flotte
in mitten in der NATO Spannungen der
schwedische Verteidigungsminister sagte
sein Land machen sich Sorgen über die
Anwesenheit der Kriegsschiffe der Ostsee
und beklagte dass die Spannungen in der
Region dadurch wahrscheinlich hoch
bleiben würden aber warum interessiert
es Russland überhaupt so sehr was Länder
wie Finnland oder Schweden tun könnten
nun keine Angst das werde ich am Ende
dieses Videos genau verstehen denn wie
ich bereits erwähnt habe sind die
Auswirkungen einer schwedischen und
finnischen Mitgliedschaft viel größer
als wir uns vorstellen können aber im
Moment müssen los lediglich darüber im
Klaren sein dass die russische Strategie
nicht funktioniert hat der Überfall auf
die Ukraine hatte unerwartete Folgen für
Russland auch wenn es das Ziel ist Krems
war ein Machtwort zu sprechen hat die
Angst vor der Irrationalität des
russischen Bären sowohl Finnland als
auch Schweden zu der Einsicht gebracht
dass das ganze Gerede von Neutralität
und allein Gängen keine Option mehr ist
ein Beitrag zur NATO war die einzige
Möglichkeit Ihre Sicherheit zu
gewährleisten und wie das Sprichwort so
schön lautet gesagt getan heute wird die
NATO Flagge bereits auf den Stützpunkten
in Helsinki aber warum dauert der
Beitrag wenigstens zur Natur so viel
länger und das hat viel weniger damit zu
tun was Schweden will denn das will
unbedingt in den NATO nein es geht
hauptsächlich darum dass es noch offene
Rechnungen mit anderen hat worüber genau
wie wir reden nun das werden wir uns
jetzt ansehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf einem langen Weg
Liebe visualpolitik-community damit ein
Land der nato-beitreten kann müssen alle
Mitglieder zustimmen bei Finnland war
das relativ einfach aber im Falle
Schwedens waren zwei NATO
Mitgliedsländer nicht gewillt das
einfach so durchzurenken das erste Land
ist die Türkei mit ihrem Präsidenten
Erdogan seit Monaten wird die türkische
Regierung Schweden vor militante
kurdische Organisation zu unterstützen
und zu beherbergten die die türkische
Regierung als terroristische Gruppen und
Staatsfeinde betrachtet außerdem hatte
Schweden bis September 2020 wegen der
türkischen Operation in Syrien ein
Embargo für waffenverkäufer an die
Türkei aufrecht erhalten und mit diesen
beiden präsidenzfällen war es klar dass
die Verhandlungen kein Zuckerschlecken
werden würden dennoch gab es am 11
September 2022 einen politischen
Richtungswechsel entstehen die Regierung
wechselte von den Sozialdemokraten zu
einer Koalition aus konservativen
Parteien diese Veränderung erleichterte
die Verabschiedung eines neuen
antikörpergesetzes das unter anderem die
schwedische Unterstützung für die Kurden
einschränkte Peter im Oktober trafen
sich Delegierte des schwedischen und des
türkischen Justizministeriums um über
mögliche Auslieferung zu sprechen die
Ankara fordert
[Musik]
und so schien trotz aller Reibungen
alles glatt zu laufen tja bis zum Januar
2023 als ich alles wieder in
Wohlgefallen auflöste damals protestiert
ein dänischer Aktivist vor der
türkischen Botschaft in Stockholm und
verbrannt sein Exemplar des Korans dies
löste große Protest in vielen arabischen
Ländern aus und zog den Zorn der
Regierung Erdogan auf sich schaut es
Euch
antry
international natürlich sagen einige
dass das alles nichts weiter als eine
Art zweitklassiges Theater war und so
könnte die Weigerung der Türkei
Schwedens akzeptieren nicht nur eine
Reaktion auf die schlechten Beziehungen
Ankara so Stockholm sondern vor allem zu
Washington gewesen sein ja ihr habt
richtig gehört zu Washington lass mich
das erklären die Beziehungen zwischen
den USA und der Türkei sind seit Jahren
ziemlich schlecht in diesem Zusammenhang
hatte Präsident beiden monatelang
mehrere Pakete mit Waffenverkäufen an
die Türkei auf dem Tisch liegen die noch
nicht genehmigt waren dazu gehört auch
der Verkauf von F16 Jets und da die USA
so versessen darauf waren das Schweden
einfach alle mal der NATO-Beitritt war
die Überraschung groß 11 juli 2023 USA
machen inmitten der NATO-Erweiterung den
Weg frei für F16 Verkäufe an die Türkei
ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass die
Türkei die Gelegenheit genutzt zu haben
scheint um Druck auf Onkel Sam auszuüben
änderte seinen Kurs und versprach auf
dem NATO-Gipfel im Juli
schwedensbewerbung im Herbst zu
ratifizieren die ungarische Regierung
die von der Wende der Ereignisse
überrascht wurde erklärte damals dass
die Abstimmung über den Beitrag
Schwedens nur eine technische Frage sei
Amtsträger der Regierung Orban
wiederholten das Ungarn nicht das letzte
Land sein werde dass dieses Abkommen
ratifiziert das einzige andere Naturland
das schwedensbeitritt ebenfalls
behindert hat war nämlich Ungarn oh ja
Erdogan und Orban was für ein Duo
Infernale es ist klar geworden dass die
Position Orbans eng mit der Ankaras
abgestimmt ist und das Parlament wird
sich erst entscheiden wenn die Türkei
ihren Segen gibt in diesem Zusammenhang
repräsentiert Schweden im Rahmen der EU
jedoch praktisch in allem das Gegenteil
dessen wo für Ungarn steht von der
Einwanderungspolitik die sich jedoch
unter der konservativen Regierung
bereits stark geändert hat über die LGBT
Politik bis hin zur sozialen
Umweltpolitik oder der Haltung zum Krieg
in der Ukraine 5 Oktober 2016 Schweden
und Ungarn mit einer Klage wegen asy
Verweigerung Schweden sie Justizminister
erworben Johannson sagte dass Schweden
Ungarn verklagen wird wenn das Land
nicht anfängt Asylbewerber aus anderen
EU-Ländern aufzunehmen 20 Februar 2019
die Beziehungen zwischen Schweden und
Ungarn frieren ein da der diplomatische
Streit eskaliert Schweden
sozialdemokratische Sozialministerin
eine gastrantel schrieb auf Twitter dass
die sieben Punkte
Familienplanungspolitik von
Ministerpräsident Viktor Orban nach den
30er Jahren recht und das was in Ungarn
passiert alarmierend ist
auch
Import
konfliktinettofer
aber wie dem auch sei unsere Prognose
ist das jeder Politiker seinen Preis hat
und Schweden am Ende so oder so der NATO
beitreten wird sollten eigentlich lieber
aufpassen dass sie während ihre
Pokerspiele und ihre Blockade und
Bremsmanöver von den anderen nicht
rechts überholt und in Sachen
[Musik]
all seine Bemühungen doch noch kolossal
zu vermasseln nun das alles werden wir
uns jetzt genau ansehen und beantworten
aufgepasst
[Musik]
das letzte Stück im Basel
in einem Bericht des internationalen
Zentrums für Verteidigung und Sicherheit
in Estland aus dem Jahr 2016 heißt es
ohne Schweden und Finnland in der NATO
fehlt es den Bündnis an strategischer
und operativer Tiefe in der Region sowie
an ausreichender Kapazität um eine
größere Kontrolle über den See und
Luftraum in der Ostsee auszuüben sollte
es Russland gelingen Stockholm und
Helsinki zu zwingen sich aus einem
Konflikt in der Ostsee heraus zu halten
während die Reaktionsmöglichkeiten der
NATO noch begrenzter aber warum ist es
für Schweden und wenn dann so wichtig
der NATO beizutreten nun die Antwort
könnt ihr auf dieser Karte sehen
nach der Annexion der Grimm im Jahr 2014
haben die USA eine Reihe von Krieg
spielen durchgeführt um nach
strategischen Schwachstellen an den
ganzen der NATO zu suchen dieses
Szenarien zeigten dass die schwedische
Insel Gotland in dem hypothetischen Fall
dass Sie die baltischen Republiken
verteidigen müsste eine Schlüsselrolle
spielen würde wenn Russland ist soweit
die Korridor abschneiden und Gotland
einnehmen würde um dort
Luftabwehrsysteme zu stationieren wie
auf der Karte sehen können Sie wissen
die baltischen Republiken praktisch in
der Falle es wäre in diesem Fall äußerst
schwierig ihnen zu Hilfe zu kommen und
es wäre nicht einmal nötig so weit zu
gehen wenn Russland die Natur daran
hinder diese Inseln zu nutzen könnte ein
Hybride Angriff auf das Baltikum selbst
mit nicht markierten Truppen wie er
bereits auf der grimmstadt fand einen
Albtraum für die atlantischen
Streitkräfte darstellen genau das ist
oder besser war einer von Russlands
großen langfristigen Trümpfen
aber warte wenn das ist noch lange nicht
alles
[Musik]
der Beitritt Finnlands und vor allem
Schwedens zur NATO macht auch den
größten Teil der strategischen Wertes
von kalinien Grad zunichte wir haben
über diese gigantische Festung Russlands
quasi mitten in Europa sogar mal ein
eigenes Video gedreht ich werde euch
verlinken aber nun könnte die NATO sehr
leicht die Verbindungen zwischen diesen
Gebiet und dem Rest Russlands Pappen die
russische Ostseeflotte die hier
stationiert ist kann sich da nicht mehr
frei bewegen und nicht nur das in einem
solchen konfliktszenario wäre Russland
nicht einmal in der Lage diese Enklave
mit Nachschub zu versorgen dass meine
Lieben Zuschauer bestärkt viele
Analysten in ihre Annahme das kann ich
ihnen gerade früher oder später sowieso
nicht mehr Bestandteil der Russischen
Föderation sein wird in diesen
Zusammenhang gilt das gleiche für die
wahren Ströme in und aus dem Weltmarkt
Russland ist stark auf den Handel über
die Ostsee angewiesen um seine Produkte
in den Rest der Welt zu liefern und zu
verkaufen jetzt werden diese
Verbindungen von der Zustimmung der NATO
abhängig sein aber es kommt noch dicker
die Fähigkeit der russischen Luftwaffe
Stellungen im restlichen Europa zu
erreichen wird ebenfalls stark
eingeschränkt mit anderen Worten während
die Ostsee Jahre lang ein von Russland
kontrolliertes Gewässer war das seiner
Marine und seine Luftwaffe Zugang zum
Herzen Europas verschaffte ist dies nun
nicht mehr der Fall die Eingliederung
von Finnland und Schweden in die Nato
hat diese Möglichkeit in keinem erstickt
in diesen Zusammenhang haben die NATO
Finnland und Estland bereits ehrgeizige
Pläne angekündigt um den Finnischen
Meerbusen notfalls schließen zu können
wohlgemerkt auch Russland hatte für 2022
Pläne angekündigt seine Seemacht in
diesem Gebiet wieder aufzubauen jetzt
sind diese Pläne im Eimer mit dem
Beitrag Schwedens und Finnlands zur NATO
wird die Ostsee von NATO-Mitgliedstaaten
umgeben sein das Ziel einer russische
Seemacht aufzubauen was 2022 mit der
Veröffentlichung der neuen militärischen
erneut programmiert wurde während dieser
strategisch wichtigen Region nun nicht
mehr realisierbar wenn die russische
Ostseeflotte damit also praktisch
Geschichte wäre würde mit einem
NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine das gleiche
mit der schwarzen meerflotte passieren
aber das ist eine andere Geschichte denn
über die Strategie der Ukraine zur
Eliminierung der russischen
Schwarzenberg Flotte werden wir euch ein
eigenes Video bringen vergesst also
bitte nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen um es
nicht zu verpassen aber um beim Thema
Schweden zu bleiben obwohl dieses Land
eine relativ kleine Armee hat bringt ist
eine wichtige Militärindustrie in das
Bündnis ein an dieser Stelle müssen wir
erwähnen dass schwedische Fabriken nicht
nur Kleinwaffen sondern auch
fortschrittliche Systeme wie
Kampfflugzeuge Raketen Panzer U-Boote
Kriegsschiffe und flugabwehrplattformen
herstellen wir glauben dass wir so
Verteidigung der Alliierten beitragen
werden wir haben zwar nicht so viele
Streitkräfte wie Finnland aber wir
verfügen über die fortschrittlichsten
Technologien und sehr starke Unternehmen
im Verteidigungsbereich mit anderen
Worten Schwedens Beitrag zur NATO ist
ohne Übertreibung einer der größten
Sprünge in Sachen Sicherheit für ganz
Europa in den letzten Jahrzehnten im
Jahr 2021 betrug die Länge der Grenze in
Russlands mit NATO-Ländern 841 km tja
und Putins militärische spezialoperation
hat dazu geführt dass nach dem Beitritt
für Finanz dies nun mehr
2100 km sind durch die Integration
Schwedens wird ist nun auch seine
gesamten Einfluss in der Ostsee
verlieren strategisch gesehen handelt es
sich also um eine kolossale Katastrophe
für Putins imperiale Pläne eine weiteres
wichtiges Puzzlestück zur Einigung der
russischen Gefahr befindet sich nun also
an seinem Platz aber es ist natürlich
nicht das letzte zu all den weiteren
Puzzlestücken werden wir euch in Zukunft
natürlich noch weitere aufschlussreiche
Videos liefern vergesst also bitte wie
gesagt nicht das Abo unbedingt mit
Glöckchen falls sie euch auch
interessieren und ihr sie nicht
verpassen möchtet und bis dahin ist
erstmal eure Meinung gefragt wie wird
Russland eurer Meinung nach auf den
nato-beitrag Schwedens reagieren meint
ihr der nächste Schritt sollte die
Abtrennung Kaliningrads vom Rest
Russland sein schreibt uns eure
Einschätzung bitte in den
Kommentarbereich unter dieses Video denn
wie immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion
und Eure Anregungen zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht noch dabei gelernt habt falls
ja gibt es bitte ein Like heißt mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen natürlich von was auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit dieses
Projekte weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr wie immer in der Beschreibung
oder ein Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]